hallo mein name ist so kann meine lieben
freunde sandra und ich haben bereits
seit monaten einen podcast namens dick
und doof den wir immer wöchentlich
donnerstags auch spotify auf apple
podcasts etc hochladen doch heute für
die letzte podcast folge dieses jahr am
zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag haben uns
gesagt dass wir zum ersten mal auch eine
podcast folge dick und doof auf youtube
hochladen und uns quasi dabei filmen von
daher wünsche ich euch jetzt viel spaß
bei dieser ersten dick und doof folge
die nicht nur auf spotify apple podcast
dieser keine ahnung wo kommt sondern
auch hier auf youtube so dass wir uns
auch zuschauen können wie wir uns
gegenseitig unsere weihnachtsgeschenke
für den anderen bereichen und macht euch
das video irgendwie im hintergrund hört
euch dort an
es ist ein bisschen länger eine podcast
folge und jetzt geht's los
es geht los
und damit herzlich willkommen wir heute
meine lieben freunde zu einer neuen
folge dick und doof und zwar zum zum
weihnachts special herzlich willkommen
wir haben hier richtig geschmückt
die leute die gerade bei spotify apple
music oder apple podcast the music music
wäre mir wahrscheinlich beide nie machen
mit unseren gesangstalenten aber die
hält trinkst du schon wieder was 20
sekunden ist die folge egal wo auch
immer ihr uns gerade hört ihr werdet es
wahrscheinlich gerade nicht sehen was
wir hier an wunderschöner deko wenn man
keine bezahlst du karte hat wird ihn nur
so hart deko ready ist folglich und cool
das ist das passt zur wohnung
stabiles material so stabil wie du ja
ich war gerade sagen stadt wieder sachen
passen halt zu meiner wohnung
aber meine lieben freunde alle die
gerade wie bereits gerade schon bereits
bereits die auch spotify oder apple
music report
direkt in die tonne kloppen gefolge alle
die uns gerade zu hören die sehen uns
nicht war der sinn ja aber weiter lust
hat und so sehen falls sie bock habt uns
zu sehen könnt ihr auf youtube gehen
denn da sind wir gerade nicht live aber
wir hängt agieren aller ersten mal und
das dachten uns ist ganz cool für die
letzte folge dieses jahr mehr für die
weihnachts folge weil wir haben jeder
ein geschenk für die andere person
vorbereitet ja ich habe hier ein
geschenk war draufsteht sander vor
weihnachten fertig opfer ich habe schöne
happy new year für luca alles gute in
schuhe merry x-mas wo ist denn dann es
dasteht x-men endlich kann ich mal wird
sie gerade auch auf youtube youtube die
folge auf nun endlich kann ich immer
sachen zeigen ja stets hier messen oder
cocktails y happy x-mas der rest der
rest ist richtig sauer
aber ja um aufs thema zu kommen herzlich
willkommen heute zur weihnachts folge so
zwar nicht weihnachten gerade kannst du
mal diese tüte jetzt aus meinen fressen
hier nehmen dass unsere schutzwand
verhindern
einfach hier soll so aufbauen dass wir
stark genug spielen können auch spielen
ohne diese sander hat auf jeden fall
eine tolle tüte mit seinem pinguinen und
ich habe sie doch dieser medizin
das wollte ich mal als green screen
benutzen das geschenkpapier aber dann
habe ich mir ein green screen gehofft
also an alle da mal ich habe noch kein
schon betrogen wir sitzen hier wieder
mit dick und doof klasse hoch wir sitzen
hier mit apfelsaft da du hast das logo
nicht zeigen und auch nicht
[Applaus]
das intro meine lieben freunde erkennt
dass ihr wisst es er liebt es ja heute
weihnachts folge zum aller ersten mal
nicht nur auf spotify apple podcast
dieser etc sondern auch auf youtube weil
ganz viele meinten hey ich hab kein
spotify kein apple music podcast dieser
whatever wer auch immer kein spotify
oder so hat keine ahnung auf welchem
planeten du lebst aber deswegen hier auf
youtube meine folge und vor allem für
die heutige folge war es halt ganz gut
weil wir die geschenke haben dann könnte
es nämlich auch sehen ist immer so eine
schöne stimme heftiges geschenk wirklich
legal ist ist hier eine weihnachtsfreude
ich dachte wir sind jetzt hier voll spaß
ich wir haben auch ich fand es auch
stark wären diese folge wirklich seit
wochen von der la vida so viel scheiße
drum herum genauso wie den spanier ich
habe es euch schon mal erzählt
deutschland sparen nachrichten ist es so
du kannst ein inhalt ein inhaltlicher
und ich war drei minuten ich kann euch
mal den chart zeigen von sander und mir
so ein paar nachrichten war ausgelöscht
damit ihr das nur das wichtigste seht ja
sowie das quasi mehr aus ich schick
sandra sprachnachrichten kann man das
erkennen ja da ich schicksal
sprachnachrichten die gehen zwei minuten
drei minuten eine minute unterschreibt
immer nur okay okay okay er sagt so
inhalt ist gut ich hole ich später vom
bahnhof ab sagte ja und du weißt ja ich
kann ich eine vom bahnhof abholen und so
richtig unmöglich ist gerückt oder
kannst meine füße waschen die sache nach
40 grad sagen wollte dachte es ist eine
schöne stimmung wir haben auch seit
wochen an alle die nicht aktiv dick und
doof hörer sind erstmal das ist unser
passiert ist noch nicht sagen das ist
unser podcast und seit monaten machen
wir wöchentlich eine neue folge augen
donnerstag jeden donnerstag 18 uhr auf
allen möglichen streaming-diensten könnt
ihr hören dick und doof heißt es falls
andreas dick und doof und ich bin luca
ich würde sagen damit man in staffel 2
machen dick und doof und luca du mit
deinem bm
ich trinke er alkoholfrei ja nie was ich
sagen wollte wir wollen uns dem glühwein
hinsetzen ja weil du kann ich habe mal
eigentlich haben wir
hat beschlossen dass worte gar nicht
trinken aber dann haben wir letztendlich
doch noch kurzfristig entschieden dass
wir doch trinken weil wir eigentlich ein
karte haben wie man beide gestern
trinken und vorgestern beim feiern
unterwegs getrennt voneinander dass
immer die schönsten abend da wenn man
sich ja ich war letztens als ich auf
meinem sofa allein und dachte mir das
hammer dass die gerade nicht hier ist
habe ich ja nicht aus freude habe ich
dann geholt
kurz dir gebetet meditiert und dann auf
jeden fall sitzen wir jetzt hier nicht
mit dem kakao oder kinder punsch oder
glühwein sondern mit ich habe dieses
jahr noch keinen glühwein getrunken
ich auch nicht da und überlegt was schon
der 16 15 hinter heute wo mein gott
ich finds echt stark wie du
zwischendurch einfach ich sag einsatz
und du sagst das letzte wort mit das ist
mit dem podcast mit catoki aufgefallen
ist so und dann müssen wir noch zu tun
guckst was ich sage ich so lewe und das
heißt auch der hamburger jetzt haben die
leute ist doppelt gehört also gut ja die
weihnachts folgen wenn die freunde wir
hoffen natürlich er hat ein
wunderschönes weihnachtsfest vorgestern
ich hoffe ihr habt ganz ganz viel
scheiße bekommen kennt ihr das erkennt
sie dass wenn ich habe mir schon meine
story erzählt dass man andauert so dm
des sets für fünf euro oder so bekommt
und das bekomme ich gefühlt 20 x oder
socken oder süßigkeiten ich esse aber du
ist die süßigkeiten und auch noch ich
hasse weihnachtssüßigkeiten so viel war
vollauf so lebkuchenherz und so
zwar mag es gar nicht oder spät war
marzipan kugeln deswegen ist der podcast
organe gleiche sagt er ganz kurz sollen
diese scheiß deko wegpacken weil ihnen
die störche zum klettern das ist das ist
unser weihnachtsbaum gewesen
es ist staub alles ja gut dann hättet
mich immer so ein bisschen dafür dass
ich nicht so in die kunst ein branchen
hausfrau da da hat sich auch darüber
gefasst mit ihrem finger lokal dieses
gerät das heißt nicht dass du die
scheiße abwischen kannst
apropos den scheiß habe ich mir schon
gut fangen wir jetzt anja wollen mit dem
anderen das geben oder wollen wir weil
du hast ja eine tüte und gibst mir die
sachen und ich hab's ja verpackt und das
ist alles in allen dingen erst einmal
kurzfristig die machen wird ist das war
ne frage ich habe was richtig dass ich
will es gar nicht wenn es klingelt schon
luca was könnte das sein
stenau jungen baldiger ich habe
dieselben diesen doch nicht oder es auf
dem wochenmarkt gehen
ich gehe mit den lebensfrohen mittel
soll ich die chance jetzt auch ein ziel
oder war der saal kam zu überlassen
essen
an alle die uns auf spotify oder apple
podcast gerade hören
dies freut euch freut euch einfach das
gefühl dass ich älter wie ich muss das
kurzem eine story fuqua bewährt das ist
ja leute wir nehmen wir gerade das
weihnachts-special auf und nicht nur den
ton sondern auch mit einer kamera die
oft zum ersten mal auch ein podcast
folge dick und doof auf youtube braucht
man mehr nicht zu sagen ja okay meine
lieben freunde also das war das erste
geschenk was du für mich hat es soll bei
mir ist es so es ist alles
zusammengepackt du wirst es auspacken
das direkt viele kleine dinge die ich
gesagt habe
oder soll ich es auspacken und die dann
die sachen daraus geben die vier sachen
du hast dich zusammen für mich also dass
wir uns noch was jetzt doch jetzt noch
zwei okay ich habe viele sachen für dich
also erst mal ich finde ich hab's mega
schön verpackt alt die fresse hat das
sieht aus wie man eine scheiße mit
durchfall zusammen vielleicht
von mir nicht mehr von mir will ich auch
gar nicht guck dir mal die scheiße an
die höhere luca ich hab heftiges
geschenk für dich das geschenkpapier
kennst du diese leute ja so oder diese
eltern also meine mama zum beispiel so
eine heißt doch nicht dass geschickt
diese zunächst zur es ist also das
allererste was ich für dich habe sandra
ist 111 stick der ist leider der ist ein
bisschen älter schon jetzt und das ding
noch dran für das wird mit einem
gebrauchten sachen geschenkt ich dachte
du hast noch sein handy
aber dann hast du ja nicht erholt und
haben es trotzdem
du kannst halt dein handy also nehmen ja
so reinpacken
du hast dann kannst du es hier
festschrauben also das jetzt relativ
locker und dann kannst du es halt aus
fahren und dann kannst du ja theoretisch
hast du so bleiben und so rumlaufen von
uns machen
sanders runtergefallen und glas
geschenkt ich abgezogen
jetzt aus wie ich gaffel kölsch glas
hier brust schön dass man gegenseitig
laser lasst uns das beste daran die
ganze also das habe ich durch gewaschen
aber das hier trinkt ein bier trinkt
apfelschorle
ich dachte hier die monetarisierung
weggenommen wird
läutet herunter gut jetzt reifen
ich bin da das foto hier jetzt mal ein
ich weiß nicht wo mein gott ok ja diesen
safestick den hab ich dir auf jeden fall
da dachte ich es passt zu deinem namen
sandra und weil du immer safesticks ganz
coolen normalerweise ist es so dass das
ding halt noch connected ist also du
hast hier sonnen sondern anschluss soll
die nur den eingang von einem handy max
und danach jeden knopf drücken studio 1
70 werbegeschenk von denen gewesen dass
ich gebraucht
aber genau das ist mein ich würde weil
ich so heißt bin schenkt man uns
gegenseitig in köln startet sind wie
alkoholiker der wahnsinn
er ist irgendwie cool dass wir zum
ersten mal die folge nicht nur auf
spotify und apple podcast und so haben
schon auch ich weiß gar nicht was sie
achten soll alter ich auch nicht wenn
normalerweise schauen wir uns immer an
als ich sie besitzer über zwei meter
auseinander setzen wir so zweiten
fenster neben der anderen person dass
ich mich zum ersten mal die ganzen käse
vielfalt seiner füße gibt einen scheiß
geschenkt ich hatte mir das für ein hat
dir das früher auf wenn ihr so geschenke
oder was war das für eine familie ist
also eure familie aber ward ihr so dass
ihr so abwechselnd und danach reihe die
geschenke ausgepackt haben wir müssen
bis jetzt noch dem es kommt bis jetzt
immer noch ein weihnachtsmann soll es
wird lan als der wald lockt ein gedicht
oder
stimmt der leute will deine gab es hier
gehen die athleten und lachte man heute
würde sondern es wird leider hat diese
erklärung allerdings nicht werten als
anders mutter du hast ja auch ein paar
schwestern und einen bruder
und dann sagt sie zählt sie ihre
schlechten zukunftsbüro erzählte unseres
schlechten und wenn die liebe drei
nichts mehr wissen wir ein
weihnachtsgedicht doch sagen
und jedes mal klingelt dieser fertigen
weihnachtszauber in unserer haustür und
kommt damit zum riesen sack voll
geschenken mit an bord kassel ist
bescheiden wenn ich viel lachte dann
juckt meine nase und läuft wie auch die
ja ich glaube du wirst ja gestehen
lachen
wir müssen jetzt mal kurz klar kommen
die sache ist an alle leute wirklich das
müssen wir in dieser folge sagen also
sorry an alle die wöchentlich hören und
auf spotify und apple podcast und so mit
dabei sind aber alle leute die gerade
die abonnenten von meinem youtube kanal
sind und nicht wissen was wir machen und
die reingehört das ist ein podcast von
sandra und mir wo wir uns am ersten
august die erste folge raus kam also vor
45 modern ja wo wir uns gesagt haben hey
immer wenn wir irgendwie zusammen feiern
sind mit freunden oder keine ahnung was
gibt so viel scheiße passiert und so
viele lustige sachen und solche dummen
themen über die wir jetzt reden und so
weiter und so fort dass wir den podcast
starten indem wir uns hat alles
gegenseitig ein bisschen erklären und
labern und irgendwie hat der podcast
solche ausmaße angenommen dass wir
niemals eigene themen sogar haben
sondern wir lagern einfach nur so schon
wieder zu ende ist man einfach nur ich
so lasst mich den erfolg der monster
berührt alter bar
auf jeden fall ja das machen was ich
will den leuten ganz noch kurz noch ein
kleiner fakt sich immer also eigentlich
rede ich und sandra sagt ich soll die
fresse das liegt das ist aldi hat
zusammen mit von unserem podcast aber
heute auf jeden fall die erste folge auf
youtube fast halb voll auf jeden fall
heute die erste folge auf youtube wir
werden das jetzt nicht wöchentlich
machen aber ich würde schon sagen ab und
zu vielleicht kann man ostereier special
oder irgendwie machen in zwei drei
monaten genommen aber stand jetzt auf
jeden fall heute die erste folge auf
youtube bald macht halt sind mit den
geschenken und damit machen wir es noch
weiter und zwar das nächste geschenk das
ist die teile heißen nicht richtig
zeigen eine kamera die teile heißen over
covers das sind so kleine plüsch dinge
die du auf deine
weißt du nicht was denkst du
was denkst du
die glocken
was wenn ich das so sehe die ja
irgendwie auch froh sind wir aber für
was für was könnte das sein
das ist ja mal darüber reden dass die
türen nicht so knallen oder wie damit ja
aber das sind ja so habe ich die nicht
daten da habe ich ihn nicht aber in
meinem schlafzimmer sind vorteile die
wir sind an der wand und dann wird das
genau da wo der türklinke wenn du die
tür doll auf machst dagegen geht darf
man so ein ding das ist für deine kamera
das kannst du auf deine kamera drauf
machen weil deine kamera macht dich
kannst du zeigen ich habe jetzt eine
ähnliche kamera wie du ja und die
kameras bei mir ist zum beispiel so ein
fetter plüsch drauf naja hier sind dass
hier die mikrofone beispielsweise diese
beiden kleinen löcher auf der kamera
obendrauf
und da kannst du das hier draufkleben
und wenn dann wind kommt geht hier
darwin 300 dann ist es halt zu bringen
blöder sound ist mir aufgefallen als sie
am bahnhof fast als ich also schnallt er
die videos für sandra auf youtube so
viel braucht eigentlich wollte ich nur
eins davon
das sind die klebe teile also du machst
und klebe ding da drauf und das
flüchtige noch so oft dass klebe ding
und das ist einfach gut wenn
windgeräusche kommen beispielsweise dass
qualität besser beispiel weil wir fahren
tatsächlich anfang januar für vier ja
nicht nur wir wissen wir sind in unserem
zu sechs glaube ich oder zu siebt
den gesunden drehe carola du ich mag das
ist mal 26 wir fahren zu sechs nach den
haag das ist ein strand badeort in
holland und die fahnder anfang januar
die dümmste idealer zeit mein luca gibt
im rbb an dass wir spazieren gehen und
fotos machen wollen nicht dass sie das
gut die beide so was wollt ihr machen
wir wollen endlich ihren videos drehen
und bisschen was trinken und so wir
haben uns für die holländische kultur
genau hier dürfte wir dürfen jetzt nicht
so reden wie wir in unserem podcast
folgen weil dort ihr müsst wissen unsere
spotify folgen sind explicit alex plett
alle alle explicit heißt dass wir
beleidigen und alles möglich also nicht
so ganz jugendfreie deswegen sind heute
ein bisschen lieber unterwegs aber ist
auch die weihnachts folge in der
weihnachtsbäckerei kein zweites mal eine
cola geklagt und normal du siehst aus
wie dieses rät ihr da nun fett und
hässlich
die konto flaschen hoch ich habe mir
beim nächsten geschenk gedacht du kam so
falls du ich hab das hatte ja alles eine
intention ganz kurz intention ja das ist
ein bierglas
ich habe mir hier richtig gedanken
gemacht ich höre ich habe mir auch
heftig gedanken ich dachte mir so ok die
spieler vom fußball wir gehen ja
meistens immer so 15.30 das abendspiel
um 18 uhr wenn ich mich nicht täusche
oder in etwa und ich dachte mir so ok
der lueg ag davor bestimmt immer zu
hause frühstücken wahrscheinlich nichts
endlich auswärts an dem tag sondern
immer schön zu hause und damals damit er
so richtig in egg fc köln stimmung kommt
habe ich hier ein glas woraus dann
wahrscheinlich schon bier trinken kannst
oder deines musikscheune eine weile
überlegt du kannst ja auch gern tost
worauf praxen du dann tust alles gedacht
ja ok es gab keine teller
das habe ich dir einfach so
schneidebretter oder nach dich
ich habe ja schon mal die untersetzer
geschenkt das heißt du kannst du bist
als richtige einstimmung falls sie mal
zum fc köln schwing ist bestimmt schon
richtig in stimmung junge schon mal
frühstück siehst du hier
die ziegel und die ziege und da wird
dann vorhalt voller erfolg für den fc
und darauf erstmal ein stück holz nach
also danke gab es irgendwie ein code in
die fc köln stopp dass du alles
dargestellt
luca nicht ich mag luca er lasst uns mal
irgendwas schenken
der stimmt du wolltest unbedingt diese
weihnachtsfeier haben hat ihr was sagen
müssen opfer
das einzigste was so max safestick geld
da ist nichts doch was der branche
ich mag autos generell ich mag flugzeuge
ja solche dem flugzeug jetskis und
keinen ding ich mag sie kein ist ein
billiges hobby
ich mag london nach hongkong london
wurde sogar zum kölner streifen war aber
nichts hintertreffen denn dein bier ist
übrigens leer sandra komm ich schütte
was ein von neuem
der apfelsaft selbst wahrscheinlich
betrinken
weil nicht so gut eingestellt aber gut
ja ich habe das war es jetzt was zu mir
geschenkt
was hätten wir dieses geschenk scheiße
beamte sachen geschenkt ich habe mir
gedanken gemacht direktor der stollen
verschenkt dem schneidebrett und glas
ich hab mir gedacht aid in deinem video
da habe ich gemerkt da war ein bisschen
zu viel finn hat habe ich die wind
covers bestellt für dich dann habe ich
dir ein kölsch ausgeschenkt weil du das
letzte mal so cool fanden trotzdem uhr
glas getrunken hast dann was habe ich
noch 111 ii stick und die letzte sagen
ich bin ich was ist ein rudi auf dem
dicker alter steht weil du immer dicker
und alter sagst ich weiß er ich wollte
erst das wodka gorbatschow logo drauf
drücken lassen das wäre das eher normal
nicht so wie du kannst mal ganz kurz und
einem pressebericht jetzt nicht ewig ich
wollte er ich wollte erst wodka
gorbatschow
ja ich wollte erst wodka gorbatschow
logo drauf drucken lassen aber ich weiß
nicht ehrlich gesagt wie es mit rechten
ausgesehen hätte und da will ich jetzt
nicht irgendwie nicht dass du den ansatz
auf einem foto und dann weißt du krank
mit weniger als vor einem ich habe sogar
noch gefragt ist ja so ein geschenk so
hast du überhaupt dran gemacht und er so
ja aber ich habe mich kaum gedanken
gemacht ja ich dachte weil du sammelst
du einen die kommst du zehnmal an mit
irgendwie sowas und schlussendlich aber
ganz ehrlich ist sogar zwei
schneidebretter dann ist er geil da wir
können sowie kölner zusammenschneiden
das ist mein geschenk auf wie willst du
deine hände sind ein messer oder was
weißt du dass ich ihn gekriegt hätte ich
gar nicht gedacht dass das ding ist ich
weiß nicht ob es verwirrt was mich was
ich dachte vier euro 95 stand auf 15
euro ok krass ja ich meine die sind auch
cool muss man sagen aber es ist halt
einfach noch heute die ziele die die so
gern mag
danke schön herr weimar linken jetzt
bist du voll ausgestattet mit einem glas
da kriegst du wahrscheinlich 1 musik
oder so aus ich bin so ein bisschen
verwirrt irgendwie gerade die ganze zeit
warum weil sie einerseits dieser
tonaufnahme nur haben
ich habe anders als auch diese kamera so
wir sind jetzt nicht so schlau und auch
nicht so multitaskingfähig meinen als
heute was ich die ganze zeit so mache
aber immer die nase juckt immer die
sache ist so kalter sonst sieht uns nie
jemand sonst sieht uns nie jemand damit
habt ja scheißegal
ja aber jetzt sehen uns auch die leute
deshalb ein bisschen verwirrend weil
gerade jetzt auch ich hatte
zwischendurch phasen wo ich eine minute
gar nichts gesagt habe ich einfach so
sagte wowereit schenkte mir auch in köln
und aachen motto und für spotify oder
wenn leute das zuhören einfach nur beim
autofahren denken sich lukas kurz aus
dem raum gegangen weil so habe ich sitze
hier und denke mir nur so was mache ich
mit meinem leben so aber deswegen ist
eigentlich ganz cool dass wir jetzt mal
diese folge haben auf youtube
ja ich wollte eigentlich als machen mit
wodka gorbatschow das hätte ich ein ganz
cool gefunden aber ich weiß halt wichtig
ist wie es mit den rechten und ich weiß
nicht ob du den angezogen hätte weil es
ist ja schon irgendwie keine ahnung
dicke alters halt lustig finde ich
hattest du je erfolg bisher mit einer
taktik hatte ich je eine person
angeschrieben und du glaubst du wirklich
bis jetzt noch nicht aber die gefahr
dass derzeit im halben jahr hier
die sache ist ich glaube ich habe
eigentlich gar keine lust auf eine
beziehung nicht zur weihnachtszeit und
soll dadurch warum sagst du hattest du
willst nur die kita gramm
ich dachte die kameras vom stativ
gefallen ist irgendwann will ich mich
vor zweitens denkt an die biologie
ich denke daran dass der planet
weiterhin mit seinen genen ja warum
ziehst dazu an diesem wenn ich schon bei
nachnamen nicht weitergeben kann mx
meine tollen gene
du kannst deinen nachnamen weitergeben
so wie ich dich kenne und wenn man
ankommt sagst du auch du hast so wie ich
mit nachnamen
das jetzt ein gelbes tuch an den haaren
aber dann hast du hier rot und grün noch
also das 3 4 nur noch blau in deinem
gesicht aber blausand ist ein schädel
weil du besoffen bist also von daher
hast du alle vier farben
die fresse ja ja wenn freunde
ansonsten war das erst mal die
weihnachtliche ich habe mal eine frage
wo siehst du denn immer die minuten lang
gesagt es gibt drei einerseits da und da
okay weil also leute unsere fahrer auf
youtube die also es ist halt irgendwie
gerade ganz komisch weil wir müssen
einerseits den leuten die nie dick und
doof gehört haben unseren podcast müssen
wir das irgendwie ein bisschen erklären
was wir überhaupt machen allerdings
nebenbei natürlich die leute und die auf
spotify uns volkswirte die hatten sich
nur unseren podcast an die folgen mir
nicht auf instagram die machen nichts
die vielheit nicht nur eine video
unseren part gehören unseren podcast
krieg so oft nachrichten von leuten die
sagen hey du bist voll der [ __ ]
aber der podcast ist echt ich bin halt
so und dann denke ich einfach nur so hey
der wird jetzt wahrscheinlich denken hat
erklärt er dass er nebenher aber ihr
werdet euch wahrscheinlich denken
zwischendurch und ich sage ja ihr wisst
welche juckt mich kotzt mich an der nase
wenn ich jetzt gar keine ahnung dann
wisst ihr nicht diese insider also das
ist ganz schwierig für uns irgendwie
aber hoffentlich ist es denn auch
irgendwie unterhaltsam
zur not findet sowieso schlecht nein ich
bin die cool aber ich nutze keine so
bretter wenn ich mitmache nämlich den
teller deinem bett so was du versprichst
mir jetzt die riechen nach tischlerei
ist doch gut
das heißt die direkte staatliche jetzt
versprechen immer ab vor bevor du zu nem
spiel fährst egal ob's aussetzung der im
märz ist im wird angehalten
hey leute da sind dann wieder die
aufnahme stoppt nach einer halben stunde
auf der kamera weil die denken solange
wollen jetzt doch nicht aufnehmen
was meinst du auswärts und invers zu
nennen wir es musste jetzt immer diese
dinge mitnehmen
mitnehmen im koffer in koffer wie mache
ich dann in werther nur wenn ihr
frühstücks bin ich zu faul das spiel ist
irgendwann den bayern oder sohn ans
schlimmste deine nacht dann sagt das
hotel die haben gesagt ich mache das
weil ich bin auch so eine
ich habe vor ich kann mich mal vor 300
so häufig in köln silvester gefeiert da
kannten wir uns noch gar nicht gab
das heißt wir waren ja auch im bootshaus
gute alte zeit halt die fresse wochen
bootshaus dann hat es mich ein kumpel
lewis abgeholt waren wir auch da ich vor
drei jahren war ich da keine ahnung
alter so und ja und dann bin ich einfach
mit so einer fetten stehlampe am schopf
gepackt ruhig so warum ist dieser
stehlampe ganz stilles wasser stehlampe
dies so hoch damit habe ich mich halt
immer geschminkt sonne und dann meinte
lewis so wenn du damit ins hotel ins
alter ich schmeiße nicht raus ich bin
als company sa lampe ein koffer zur
registrierung gegangen die sowas so war
es fast bis zur rezeption rezeption und
im und am 1 die so was ist das für eine
lampe ich sie brauche ich zu weihnachten
haben wir auch akzeptiert
ich brauche diese lampe zum einschlafen
und zum schminken kein licht im
badezimmer das okay aber hotel spa
katastrophe ja herzlich
und ruft meine lieben freund gefällt
unsere themenauswahl hier ich jetzt in
vier gleich große kommt auch immer auf
der kamera
weil ich die ganze höher als du
ja ok besitzt aber nicht so du sitzt ja
ich sitze müssen ja eingemummelt auf
jeden fall genau war das jetzt aber erst
mal unsere folge sollten wir uns die
abnehmende sich ja alles in der hand
haben uns gegenseitig erzählt die
geschenke gemacht ich habe ich denke
noch mal kurz präsentieren ja kommen
können mal machen also ich hab es andere
geschenk diese wind covers für die
kamera dann habe ich ihr den safestick
geschenkt zum sex machen und habe ich
ihr ein gaffel kölsch glas geschenk zum
trinken und einen rudi auf dem dk alter
steht weil sandra eigentlich der ganze
wortschatz bei ihr besteht aus der bau-
und alt ich habe ja geschenkt die sie
darf spalten die darf auch gern wieder
mitnimmt
aber das sieht schon auf holz welches
ist echt cool das ist wirklich cool das
ist viel cooler als das handy beide cool
finde das schön muss ich sagen ja ich
finde generell kölsch gläser sind sind
generell troll aus da die sind cool aus
ja nee das war auf jeden fall die
geschenke die wir uns gegenseitig
gemacht haben
die sache ist allerdings die folge ist
ja die letzte folge des jahres na ja
also 26
die nächste also wenn ich das gerade
hört an dem tag wo die folge raus kommt
es gerade 26 ich weiß bei youtube ist es
so dass sehr viele leute natürlich wenn
wieder online geht ist die meisten
klicks machten video eigentlich
innerhalb der ersten stunden nachdem es
online ist war bei podcast ist es
wirklich so ist es nicht die vollen geht
online und alle hören die sondern es ist
so geht man denkt sich dazu am
donnerstag die sets online am samstag
setzt sich vier stunden zug dann recht
genau so nach dem motto deswegen aber
für euch zur info die gerade die folge
hier hören
der tag wo die volle rauskam ist der 26
das heißt die letzte folge ist ja das
war die nächste folge samt zweiter
januar und von daher möchte ich mich
erst mal gedanken bei dir sandra dass
wir hier so lang durchgezogen haben
heftig
die vier fünf monaten wären die ganzen
august september oktober november
dezember fünf monate alter hatten wir
hier wöchentlich und lagern scheiße in
dieses mikrofon und so kann ich habe da
habe ich noch nie so krasse probleme mit
waren treffen wir uns da muss man auch
dazu sagen dass es ist sehr kompliziert
dass wir ein treffpunkt immer finden
die sache ist wahrlich arbeit halt
wirklich von montags bis freitags und in
diesen fünf tagen kann ich nicht das
heißt luca und ich haben rein
theoretisch nur samstag und sonntag um
uns irgendwo zu treffen
wenn ich dann beispielsweise mal am
wochenende jetzt in berlin war müssen
wir halt vor produzieren und so dass es
schon in organisatorischer aufwand
gleich darauf in voller wäre es wirklich
wenn man überlegt wenn du vielleicht
weil sie nicht irgendwann nach in die
schweiz ist kannst du dir zwar nie
leisten aber so nach motto dann dass du
das equipment mit nimmst du nach dem
motto und dann können wir nach motto
nach dem motto dann nach dem motto so
aufnehmen achso online offline
wir telefonieren und dann sprichst du
das bei dir ein ich bei mir dann schickt
man die dateien und so kann man es auch
machen aber da wir auch schon darüber
geredet unser podcast wird nicht
funktionieren wenn wir uns in puncto ich
auf dem mond so nach dem motto weise
sehr lustig weil er hätte wäre schweren
los und wird wahrscheinlich von mikro
wegfliegen aber willst du auf dem mond
oder angst davor verlieben sich für mich
und da wollen die mich auf dem planet
haben
aber ich wollte eigentlich wieder auf
die erde was macht denn dann aber zurück
taxe taxiruf kennt ja ich glaube ich auf
dem mond ich hatte auch viel zu sehen
ich bin so zufrieden auf der erde es
gibt ja die leute denken weltraum noch
nicht erforscht ich habe meine kneipe
hinnehmen
super text du dass du diese fragen musst
alter die denkst behörden ihre kinder so
oder war ich dachte ganz so sie wieso
hasen abhängen aber anscheinend muss man
die ja dann dass ich dadurch werden wo
ich aber auch gerade noch kurz darauf
hinaus wollte weil die folge geht auch
nicht mehr so lang aber ich hatte einen
noch zwei drei sachen dass er die letzte
folge des jahres ist ja am ende des
jahres reflektiert man immer das jahr
ich wollte wirklich gerne fragen was was
was ist dieses jahr bei dir passiert
weil ich meine bei mir bin ich ganz
ehrlich erzählt erst mal du was ist so
was hat dich gefreut an dem jahr was war
also die lade die sache ist für die
leute die gerade auf youtube zu schauen
ja ich habe vorgestern am 24 ein video
hochgeladen wo ich mein ja so ein
bisschen zusammengefasst habe
deswegen werde ich jetzt nicht noch mal
sagen also an alle die gerade zu hören
entweder spotify apple podcast oder zu
gucken ich auf youtube schaut euch das
video gerne an am 24 dezember ich in
österreich urlaub einfach ein bisschen
gelagert was ging auf dieses jahr aber
was ging bei dir so ab und was sind vor
allem deine ziele für das nächste jahr
das ist ja eine abschließende frage hole
ich habe also ich war in der schule bis
april
danach hatte ich drei monate
vorbereitungszeit in der zeit habe ich
öfter gesoffen als gelernt hab mein abi
deswegen nicht bestanden
dann wollte ich eigentlich nach köln
ziehen und bankkauffrau werden aber weil
ich mein abi geschafft haben nicht
geschafft haben das halt alles irgendwie
so in die quere hat mich dann halt noch
mal bei uns in bielefeld beworben und
hab dann halt auch eine
ausbildungsstelle gefunden und jetzt
mach ich halt eine ausbildung und fick
dich junge soll für die kamera presse ja
dann haben wir ich glaube ich habe eine
ausbildung angefangen ich hab podcast
glaubst du hast ne ausbildung und im
podcast auf genau angefangen
ich glaube dann so die zwar in sachen
die mich am meisten in dem jahr geprägt
haben und interessanten was ist so also
bist du ein mensch der sich so ziele
setzt dann fürs nächste jahr oder bist
du so für mich ist das ein tag wie ein
anderer weil ich denke mir so ein tag
wie ein
ich habe total viele freundinnen die
sagen bot zwar noch mal einfach mal kurz
flex nicht hoch viele freundinnen ja ich
hab den keeper danny boyle jahr 2020
wird voll mein letztes jahr haben sie
das genauso gesagt wenn ich denke mir so
was du bist du genau so nein überhaupt
nicht
überhaupt nicht so weit bist du denke
hey leute wenn ihr euch so wenn ihr euch
das nicht vornimmt oder euch so in dem
sinne so nicht wünsche aus dass die
täter und 20 so geil wird und das ist
das beste jahr meines lebens dann wird
direkt scheiße ich für mich ist das ein
tag wie andrea nur dass man in der zeit
ein grund hat sie ja um es offen zu
gehen so gut ich find erwartungen oder
die erwartung ist zu krank erwartungen
man sollte auch nicht sagen
eine alle denken ja mal dass es die
nacht meines lebens alter in dem ich
meine es gar nicht auf den er auf den 31
zwölfter gezogen sondern ich meine auf
das komplette jahr beziehung allein
viele sind dann so er ich will jede
woche vier mal ins schwimmen gehen und
jede genommen aber alle games machen im
januar habe ich denn so krank melden
sich wirklich mal sehr viel an aber was
ich sagen wollte ist es ist sehr man da
wird nur frustriert wenn man sich zum
ziel gesetzt also klar hohe ziel ist
nichts mit 922 bin ich 30 kilo weniger
alter ich meine ziele sind gut damit du
dich daran orientieren kannst vielleicht
bisschen höhere ziele aber auf jeden
fall hohe ziele sind gut und auch
wichtig damit man selbst hat weil wenn
ich jetzt sage ja ich will heute zwei
schritte zu fuß gehen weil sie so nach
dem motto anstatt dessen klage ich will
zehn kilometer joggen dann ist auch blöd
weil dann feiere ich mich dafür aber
dass sich zwei schritte gegangen und
habe sei kein fortschritt
aber man sollte sich realistische ziele
setzen also ziele sollten immer sachen
die man erreichen will
aber jetzt nicht so was wie es gibt ja
leute die sagen ja ich will jede woche
vier mal ins schwimmen und mich noch
fünf tagen gehen und ich will einen
freund und dann möchte ich mal genannt
und sieben kinder und da sind sachen die
noch teilweise einfach gar nicht
zusammenklappen
sowohl es sollten nicht einzelne der
anderen sache leiden und er war der
erwartungshorizont sollte jetzt nicht so
ins überdimensionale unendliche
hochgehen finde ich das ist sehr wichtig
bei so jahres versetzen aber ich bin
genauso wie du ich hab nur erwartungen
ans nächste jahr ich glaube sie sagen
muss das letzte jahr war cool ich habe
coole sachen gemacht so und ich bin froh
dass alle meine freunde noch immer mal
alle meine freunde sind dass ich in dich
so krassen verlust hatte in dem sinne
und ja das ist es so und ich bin also
ich hoffe dass es im nächsten jahr
genauso wird aber ich bin jetzt nicht so
jamann es wie du meintest 2020 wird so
so so und so es ist auf jeden fall so
dass ich das genauso sehen wie du also
von wegen tag wie jeder andere auch
allerdings was man an in denen die
richtung natürlich auch noch sagen muss
ich könnte jetzt auch sagen der 23 juli
ist für mich der neustart weil jeder
viele sagen auch ja aber ab dem ersten
erst beginnt alles wieder von vorne das
ganze jahr
ja aber man kann auch sagen am 23 das
ganze jahr wieder und dann sehen wir uns
am 23
nächstes jahr wieder dann ging auch
alles wieder seinen weg weist das ist
also ich finde es immer so blöd
sollte sich am datum festhaltung ihre
ziele zu machen so wenn ihr was ändern
wollt an eurem scheißleben dann macht es
gefälligst jetzt vor mir überlegt mal
das ist was an alle leute diese unserem
podcast nicht hören
wir sind ganz oft so dass sie am anfang
scheiße labern wenn wir im thema drin
sind sind wir auf einmal übels lieb
alter du wahrscheinlich noch nie so
richtig geht ja ich weiß
das ist immer so mit sandra sie sagte
eine aussage ich sagt nächstes nicht
sondern sagt sie okay stimmt und dann
trägt sie einfach nur ja genau das
wollte ich nicht auf jeden fall fragen
also was seine bucket list so ein
bisschen ist das irgendwelche ziele zu
den reisen willst ja mal am 22
und darum werden fliegen also doch erst
heute dass sie es nicht
gefühlsecht ich glaube ich bin traurig
darüber bis das nehme aber um auf das
thema mal auch ganz kurz zu sprechen zu
kommen
verhütung ist wichtig mal ganz kurz
wieder einen raushauen hier also das
heißt ein rausch soll letztlich einen
job raus zu hauen aber um euch ein
bisschen was mit zu gehen
wir werden jetzt wichtig wenn wir
irgendwann mal stress bekommen mit dem
deutschen land oder so was sie sagen
oder podcast gesperrt sein
bildung ist wichtig um verhütung werden
diese spaß ist hier also eine vierte
klasse der grundschule eingeladen
die beiden erklären euch jetzt warum er
unbedingt vermuten sollte leute ist voll
cool durex gefühlt hey es gibt auch
geschmäcker
dich eigentlich zu mit einer tüte hier
nicht wenn diese teuer merry x-mas ich
mache ich mache jetzt mal kurz
ok ich weiß auch nicht ob es die ganze
zeit eventuell stört dass wir diese
scheiß teile auf dem kopf hatten
pink alter das ich fühle mich ein
bisschen wie du dich verstört sie zu
weihnachten nicht aus zucker 0 ich sehr
cool aus ich sehe auch so ein bisschen
wie sonst mit sonder kennt sie die
russen müssen kommen
apropos russen sunrise russland hat mir
vor zwei folgenden russisch beigebracht
und schlussendlich kam der scheiße
scheiße war's ja sagen werden dass in
solchen fragen willst du bist du so eine
die dann so ihre sei allgemein so die
leute die whatsapp stories machen ich
habe früher einmal eine gemacht und dann
würde ich auch sagen schon bruder was
passiert meine tante macht immer meine
beiden tanten machen immer whatsapp
stories also und so also wenn ich so
ältere leute bei uns zum beispiel meine
arbeitskollegen eben auch andauernd
status
daran denke ich gar nicht mehr ich hab
akku leer story was hast du ja ich hab
mir abgeguckt haben wir den salat
einfach als status
das hier sind so solches sollten keine
ahnung erwirkt bist du seine person die
dann wirklich dann so auch so egal ob
nicht verstehst mich wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr
du hast meine neuen vorsätze fürs jahr
noch nicht ich finde paar leute
übertreiben ihre lage und ein foto vom
weihnachtsbaum und so mal klar es ist
irgendwie schön dass der mikro
weggedreht
aber ich finds auch stark wie wir zu
beginn der folge noch beide wirklich so
saßen
und jetzt sitzen wir beide jg
zwischendurch in dem podcast folgen soll
es gab ja folgen wo wir auch schon
unfassbar krass gelacht haben und dann
aufgestanden sind und so das zimmer
gelaufen bin
hast du geschrieben alles gute zu
weihnachten ja warum alles gut du bist
du total es selber so also zwischen ich
hab's folgender sachsenweg so einfach
nur eingelagert
aber ja das wäre auf jeden fall die
weihnachts folge wir hoffen natürlich es
hat euch gefallen hat youtube und
spotify dieser und apple podcast
eingefallen ja genau also ich glaube es
war an einigen stellen für verschiedene
leute auf verschiedenen plattformen
bisschen komisch weil die sache ist ich
glaube wir haben viel zu wenig erklärt
für ihn nur podcasthörer für die nur
podcast stimmen
die geschenke ja da habe ich gar nicht
drüber nachgedacht er übers tor als dann
alle leute die nur unseren ton gehört
haben auch spotify oder äpfeln oder
sagen also was wenn aliens die folge
schickt zur abnahme und dann bin ich
gespannt alter wie es ja weil sonst ist
es immer so wenn die kamera nicht läuft
dann erklären wird halt nicht wie die
leute und ich sag's zusammen hat mir
hier ein klares geschenkt wo spürbar an
das erste fc köln draufsteht
so nach dem motto dann sag ich selber
sagen hat mir hier ein holzbrett
geschenk mit dem ersten fc köln logo
drauf so ist das halt erklärt david das
video aufnehmen ich das einfach hoch
gelacht so nach dem motto aber nochmal
für die leute im podcast also sander hat
ein dicker alter schwarzen hut bekommen
oder schaut euch einfach die folge noch
mal auf youtube dafür interessiert sonst
folgt uns gern auf instagram adcell visa
und laser luca oder die condor folgen
oder ihr könnt auch zudem zu sein direkt
zusammen oder ihr könnt auch dick und
doof auf ins amt
da werdet ihr die bilder sehen zu den
geschenken unter anderem von podcasts
definitiv nächste woche wieder daran
donnerstag in jahren das heißt thorsten
rutscht gurken und kondome klein las die
kondome knollen das nicht so gut dann
platzen lassen
ich muss jetzt gehen wir nicht ab guten
rutsch
ich hoffe hat ein schönes weihnachtsfest
wir sehen uns nächste woche donnerstag
wir hoffen euch hast den hallen hat man
alle leute auf youtube lässt gerne
daumen hoch da abonniert gerne einen
kanal und so wie das heute nicht so viel
geschnitten war und keine
hintergrundmusik und so aber war halt
einfach viel haben sich gewünscht dass
diese weihnachtsfeier auf youtube online
geht damit die geschenke sehen haben wir
viele nachrichten bekommen deswegen der
jugend
[Musik]